to attend to a Prayer by house chaplain
Reverend brod Stewart pastor of Saint
Paul's United Methodist Church in
Manchester
good morning Mr Speaker and good morning
New Hampshire House of Representatives
Happy New Year to all of you
let us all be in a spirit of Prayer
oh God we come with gratitude for this
new year
this new day
and then this new house session for
2023.
you have called us o God to do the work
of this great state of New Hampshire
you have called us to be careful in
efficient stewards
to this end we bind together as one body
for the State of New Hampshire
we seek your guidance for This House of
Representatives
and we seek your help to govern them
throughout their work
be with each member as they navigate
through all the pressing matters that
come before them today and in the days
that lie ahead
give wisdom and vision oh God to those
who serve as representatives for the
people of their communities
and God guide all the leaders that are
gathered here today and that in turn
through their leadership
they may lead and guide this body to the
best of their ability
we ask that you keep your hand upon each
leader
and upon each representative to
accomplish the tasks set before them
may all gathered here today work
together in harmony
for the good of this state and for the
good and Welfare of the people
oh God in all our discussions today
give us the clarity and help us in the
understanding of differing views
in our voting give us wisdom and
integrity
and let it be the voice of the people
o loving and gracious God
be with us
and help this to be a fruitful
both personally and professionally
we ask all this in the name of you who
has created everything into being
amen
chair recognizes the member of
Peterborough representing Jonah wheeler
who will lead us in the Pledge of
Allegiance
energy
the chair recognizes Lucius nearing of
Dover who will sing our national anthem
oh say can you see by the dawn's early
light what so proudly we he held at the
twilight's last gleaming
whose broad stripes and bright stars
through the perilous
fight or the
ramparts we watched were so
gallantly
streaming
and the
rockets red glare the bombs bursting
[Music]
gave proof through the night
that our flag was still there
oh say does that Star Spangled
Banner yet wait
[Music]
or the last
Land of the Free
and the home of
the brave
[Music]
[Applause]
the house will attend a request for
thank you
I could have made you stand for the
whole session but
the house will attend to request for
leaves of absence Mr Speaker the day
illness Representatives Bartlett conlon
Granger Hamlet Seth King partial the day
important business Representatives Barry
D Silvestro Catherine Kenny Khan
spilsberry and trottier the day illness
in the family representative Anita
Burroughs
these leads the Rapture shall be granted
unless otherwise ordered by the house
the house will attend the introduction
of guests Mr Speaker please welcome
Anthony Henry student at Pinkerton
Academy in Dairy our page for the day
[Applause]
Welcome to the New Hampshire house
[Music]
[Applause]
Mr Speaker please welcome Stacey Brooks
Donna and Morgan Makai guests of
Representatives groda Malloy Balboni and
Maggiore Gene Taylor spouse of
Representative Schultz Aaron bolia son
of representative Harvey bolia they are
with us in the gallery today
Welcome to the New Hampshire house
[Applause]
the house will attend to a communication
Mr Speaker
the letter dated December 21st 2022 Paul
Smith Clerk of the house dear Paul
please be advised that the following
Representatives elect were sworn into
office by the governing executive
Council on this day Hillsboro district
18 Juliette Smith Stratford County
District 12 Kenneth Vincent sincerely
David M Scanlon Secretary of State
Welcome to the New Hampshire house
[Applause]
[Music]
the house to attend to further
communication
Mr Speaker in an email on December 22nd
dear Clerk and members of the house I
would like to inform you that I am
choosing to resign from my re-elected
position as a state representative from
Nashua Ward 4. I representative elect
Stacy Marie Lawton of Nashua New
Hampshire award for Hillsborough County
District 3 have chosen to resign for my
re-elected position as a state
representative it is with a heavy heart
that I have to Tender my resignation it
has been in honor of a lifetime to serve
in the New Hampshire house over the last
two years and I ran again knowing I
could serve again over the next two
years however certain life events have
come up that will make it difficult for
me to serve my next term I believe
ethically I must step aside and allow a
special election to take place to fill
my vacancy I will continue to remain
engaged in my community and serve my
neighbors many blessings Reverend Stacy
Marie Lawton
the resignation is accepted a house will
tend to a resolution
Mr Speaker Representatives Osborne and
Wilhelm offer the following resolved
that the House of Representatives and
formed the honorable Senate it is ready
to meet in joint convention for the
purpose of canvassing the votes for
governor and executive Council
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
there's opposed nay the guys have it and
the resolution is adopted
yeah recognize the clerk Mr Speaker the
Senate is now ready to meet with the
House of Representatives and Joint
convention for the purpose of canvassing
the votes for governor and executive
Council
the house will come to order chair
recognizes Sergeant at Arms
everything
while we're waiting for our
Senate colleagues with members turn on
your voting stations make sure you turn
them on
Mr Speaker chair recognizes
sergeant-at-arms
Mr Speaker The Honorable Senate
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
very nice
Christmas Jay recognizes Sergeant at
Arms
Mr Speaker president of the Senate The
Honorable Jeb Bradley of Wolfeboro
[Applause]
The Joint convention will come to water
The Joint convention has been formed for
the purpose of canvassing votes for the
governor and executive Council
The Joint convention will attend to a
resolution
Mr Speaker representative Osborne and
Senator Carson offer the following
resolved at The Honorable Secretary of
State be requested to lay before the
joint convention the return votes for
governor and executive Council are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye there's opposed nay the
eyes have it the resolution is adopted
the chair recognizes his sergeant in
arms
so much
Mr Speaker New Hampshire Secretary of
State David M Scanlon
[Applause]
thank you
Mr Speaker Mr President
and honorable members of the general
court
as required by articles 42 and 60 part
two of the New Hampshire Constitution
the secretary of state is required to
appear before you on this day to present
the return of votes for governor and
executive Council from the general
election that was held on November 8th
for the office of governor
in Belknap County Christopher sununu
received twenty thousand four hundred
and forty nine votes Tom Sherman
received 9429
in Carroll County sununa received 16
554 votes
Sherman received 10 306.
in Cheshire county sununa received 16
503 votes Sherman received sixteen
thousand eight hundred and ninety in
koas County sununu received 8 251 votes
Sherman received 4194.
Grafton County sununa received 20 427
votes
Sherman received 21 483.
Hillsborough County sununa received 99
608 votes Sherman received 69 673.
Merrimack County sununa received 38
669 votes Sherman received thirty
thousand eight hundred and thirty five
Rockingham County
sununa received 92 043 votes Sherman
received 59 759.
in Stratford County sununa received 29
100 votes Sherman received twenty six
thousand four hundred and ninety five
Sullivan County
sununu received 11
159 votes
Sherman received 7702.
in total Chris sununa received 352 813
votes
Tom Sherman received 256
776 votes
there were also two libertarian
candidates that ran for governor Carlin
borosenko received
2772 votes Statewide
and Kelly halderson received 5071 votes
Statewide
Chris sununu having a plurality of
ninety six thousand forty seven votes
was elected governor
for executive Council and the first
district Joseph Kenny received 63 230
votes
data Hilliard received 59 060 votes
having a plurality of 4170 votes Joe
Kenny was elected executive counselor
in the second district Cindy warmington
received 74 107 votes
Harold French received 49 428 votes
having a plurality of twenty four
thousand six hundred and seventy nine
votes
Cindy warmington was elected executive
counselor
in the Third District Janet Stevens
received 69
898 votes Catherine haraki had 61 506
votes
having a plurality of 8 392 votes Janet
Stevens was elected executive counselor
in the fourth district Ted gassis
received 58 123 votes
Kevin Kavanaugh received 52 858 votes
having a plurality of
5265 votes Ted gatsis was elected
executive counselor
in the Fifth District Dave wheeler
received 61 044 votes
shoshona Kelly received 55 692 votes
having a plurality of 5 352 votes
Dave wheeler was elected executive
counselor
that concludes my report before you I
wish all of you a productive session and
I hope this was the driest speech that
you'll hear for the next two years
thank you
[Applause]
The Joint convention will attend to a
resolution Mr Speaker representative
Osborne and Senator Carson offer the
following resolved that to vote for
governor and the executive Council be
referred to a committee consisting of
three on the part of the house and two
on the part of the Senate to compare and
count the same and Report thereon
are you ready for the question all those
in favor to say aye
oh suppose nay your eyes have it and the
resolution is adopted chair appoints
representative Stephen Smith
representative Sanborn Senator Wilhelm
Senators Carson and Senator Susie
representative Osborne and Senator Casa
moved at the Joint convention arise are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
those opposed A the eyes haven't in the
joint convention is adjourned
[Applause]
foreign
the house will attend to Memorial
remarks
chair recognizes representative naughter
for Memorial remarks for The Honorable
Philip straight
morning colleagues
Memorial remarks for representatives
from the town of Merrimack including
those
for the late Tony Pellegrino
this year we lost the honorable Phil
Strait
there's just no talking about Phil
without also mentioning Tony
the two went together like the two old
men in the balcony on The Muppet Show
that's always what I thought of when I
rode with them to Concord
Phil lived about a mile south of my
house while Tony lived a mile North
we tried rotating drivers for a while
but it made the most sense to just have
fill Drive
I sat in the back seat and my view was
the back of the heads of Statler and
Waldorf
sometimes our late speaker dick hinch
would ride up with us it was comedy the
whole ride up
there's just something about the way men
talk to each other that I find amusing
Phil straight served two terms he was
the vice chair of Veterans Affairs
for the town he served on many levels
including the Watson Park gazebo
subcommittee
he had a degree in agriculture
I saw him in the park one day with a
book four inches thick on the subject
just some light reading while he waited
for the rest of us to to meet him there
to campaign
we took out our ads together
Waldorf Statler and I
selfies were a new thing at the time and
we still had an actual Town paper
that's where I sent our re-elect selfie
picks
Phil spoke with an accent that I thought
was Southern but was in reality
Midwestern
every time he said hinch I would laugh
speaker hinch didn't understand why it
was funny it just was
now Phil wasn't without opinions
we probably all have a constituent or
two that we could swear have no life at
all outside their keyboard and social
media
non-stop lecturing rants
needless to say we'd have differing
opinions on just about everything with
such a constituent
Phil Phil summed one of them up one time
said
she's like a rabid animal that sinks her
teeth in doesn't let go
even so he would show nothing but
kindness to individuals like that which
always impressed me
he was a good guy
I think one of my favorite things about
Bill was that he was a huge fan of
Ronald Reagan
my youngest son used to host a birthday
party every year on February 6th
our friend representative Mooney was in
attendance every time
she can attest that it was a big deal
cake jelly beans stand up Reagan DVD
playing in the background and Reagan
gifts that varied year to year
Phil contributed to the memorial display
with Reagan items from his private
collection
sometimes I would find Reagan items on
our front doorstep
like Santa Claus he would arrive while
we were sleeping and leave gifts for my
son
he was so generous
I wish you all could have known him
his first term was my second term
my state house bestie at the time was
the former representative Lynette
Peterson
I love her to death but if you knew her
you would understand this next line
poor Phil had to sit next to her
his first term up there towards the back
of section two
from section four I could see him trying
to conceal a belly laugh
Lynette has that effect on some people
for others not so much
we affectionately called representative
straight Uncle Phil
when Lynette and I checked our mail in
the ante room Lynette thought it would
be funny to stuff all our unwanted mail
in Phil's nail slot
she would wave me over and say come on
Janine let's go see if Uncle Phil got
any mail
it never stopped being funny
to us
and we're not supposed to do that by the
way so don't
when Phil passed away this fall I met
his daughter at the services
I told Brenda that her dad talked about
her all the time
she knew who I was too and it was like
two sisters who were raised apart
meeting for the first time
she wanted to hear all the stories and
see all the pictures
I practically wrote her a whole book
like I did for Tony Pellegrino's
daughter
there's just too much to say for a reps
Hall Memorial
I will tell you this
she loved hearing all the stories and
she cherished every picture I sent
so if you have any pictures of Tony or
Phil please send them to me and I'll
send them on to his family
that aren't his daughters both of whom I
consider family because as you all know
or you will know
this body in a sense is a family
and the bond is lifelong
I miss you Uncle Phil
and you too Tony
and all the others from this legislative
family who have been called home
May their memories be eternal
thank you
[Applause]
the household please arise for a moment
of silence
foreign
chair recognizes representative Rhodes
for Memorial marks for Henry Parkhurst
colleagues I rise today to offer
Memorial remarks in the remembrance of
The Honorable Henry A.L Parkhurst of
Winchester
while I was gallowing this vast list of
accomplishments that representative
Parkhurst has acquired
I started thinking that this man just
may be the very reason that the term the
man the myth the legend has came about
or very possibly the song by Frank
Sinatra I Did It My Way
honorable Henry Parker served 18 years
which we all know to be nine terms and
the New Hampshire House of
Representatives serving Winchester on
the resources Recreation developmental
committee
he served in the U.S Coast Guard
he was the moderator of the town of
Winchester school district for 23 years
at the time of his passing he was the
committee chairman for the Winchester
Cemetery Board of Trustees which he
served on for 41 years
Henry served on the town's Community
Center Board of incorporators for over
25 years and oversaw the Boston cane for
25 years
additionally Henry was a swim instructor
it let me not forget his actual career
Henry retired from teaching school
and this is still being a little bit
debated
after 25 plus years
now if this isn't enough to make you all
reflect on the fact that we may not be
doing nearly enough
what Henry was most proud of was his
crowning title of Mr Pickle
Winchester has an annual Pickle Fest
that has been running for 25 years
strong
after the first year Henry was crowned
Mr Pickle and has been the only person
to hold said title
giving away the New Hampshire house
honors and celebrates St Patrick's Day
well this gave another reason to
dust off and wear the top hat and green
jacket
well I was talking with our house clerk
about representative Parkhurst he was
laughing while he was telling about
numerous encounters he and others had
had with Henry over his 18 years in the
House of Representatives
honestly he couldn't stop laughing
then many many of you many people in
town
that I spoke with immediately mentioned
the toes
everybody knows that Henry wore
open-toed sandals everywhere
no matter the weather
I'm quite proud of my shoes and to walk
into a room I mean exhibit a
and to have his toes be more spoke about
the my shoes I'm like dude
but it happened I had to I had to yield
sorry
Henry wanted to make everybody laugh and
he wanted a reaction out of you and I
didn't have a whole lot of interactions
with Henry but what I did have was
rememberable and I'm just going to share
one classic story with you that is going
to go down in history
this is going to sound like I'm telling
you all a joke but I'm not this is a
true story
to say our school deliberative was going
off the rails would be an understatement
being very discouraged with the chaos my
friend Mary approached the microphone
she stood tall
and she said
Mr moderator
what are the rules We are following here
are they Robert's rules are they
parliamentary procedure what's Mr
moderator what are these roles
Mr moderator firmly looked at her right
in the corneas and he said
we're following my rules the rules of
Henry
Mary looked at him not satisfied with
this answer and asked
would you care to share what those rules
are with the rest of us Mr moderator
well Henry stood even taller
kind of smirked a little in this very
nonchalant manner said
clearly they're evolving as we go
Representatives whether you knew Henry
is representative Parkhurst
Mr moderator Mr chairman Mr Parkhurst or
Mr Pickle
you knew who Henry was and you will
remember him
to the man the myth the legend
you did it your way and you will be
terribly missed
thank you Mr Speaker
the house arrives for a moment of
silence
[Applause]
chair recognizes representative Wilhelm
thank you Mr Speaker I moved that both
sets of Memorial remarks be placed in
the permanent Journal without objection
the house will attend to the
introduction of bills
Mr Speaker representative Osborne offers
the following resolve that in accordance
with the list in the possession of the
cleric house bill is number 10 15 20 30
through 52 54 through 219. house
concurrent resolutions numbered one
through four house resolutions 7 through
12 and Constitutional Amendment
concurrent resolutions one through seven
shall be by this resolution read a first
and second time by their enlisted titles
and referred to the there and designated
committees
are you ready for the question all those
who've ever say aye
those opposed nay you guys have it the
resolution is adopted
representative Osborne and Wilhelm move
the adoption of an amendment to house
rule 66 as proposed by the rules
committee and has printed in the house
calendar are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it the amendment is
adopted
representative Osborne and Wilhelm move
the adoption of an amendment to house
rule 20 as proposed by the rules
committee and is printed in the house
calendar
[Music]
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
those opposed nay the eyes have it
amendment is adopted
representative Osborne Wilhelm moved the
adoption of amendment to a house rule 43
as proposed by the rules committee and
is printed in the house calendar
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
as opposed nay the eyes have it
amendment is adopted
representative Osborne and wilha move
the adoption of an amendment to house
rule 44A as proposed by the rules
committee and is printed in the house
calendar
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye those opposed nay your
eyes have it amendment is adopted
Representatives Osborne Wilhelm move the
adoption of an amendment to house rule
52 as proposed by the rules committee
and is printed in the host calendar
I recognize representative Stephen
Pearson thank you Mr Speaker
I make emotion a friendly motion to
table
this
the question the motion is the table
are you ready for the question
although all those in favor say aye
those opposed May
the eyes have it
okay bling motion passes
representative Osborne Wilhelm moved the
adoption of an amendment to house rule
64 as proposed by the rules committee
and printed in the house calendar
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
Paul's nay the eyes have it and the
amendment is adopted
for moving on to floor amendments
representative Wilhelm moves at
Amendment 22 to rule 22c
chair recognizes representative Wilhelm
to speak to his motion
favorite
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker I rise today in support of an
amendment to house rule 22 which aims to
provide proxy voting privileges to house
members unable to attend session due to
medical condition illness or illness in
the family
Mr Speaker On organization day last
month we know that there were members of
this body who did not attend house
session because they were hospitalized
or they had tested positive for covet
19.
for those who have returned to health
and have been sworn in we give thanks
and welcome them back today
Mr Speaker today on convening day we
know that there are members of this body
who are not in attendance because they
are hospitalized or they've tested
positive for covet 19.
we offer our thoughts and prayers to
those who are not with us today with
sincere hope for a Swift and healthy
recoveries
Mr Speaker we know that on future
session days there will be members of
our body who will not be in attendance
due to hospitalization or medical
condition or because they will test
positive for covid-19 or the flu
or because they need to care for a
family member who might be ill
with such a closely divided chamber we
all know that attendance will matter
more than ever this term
just as important as our votes
is our ability to keep one another
healthy and safe as citizen legislators
as volunteers and as Granite Staters
this rule Amendment simply allows for a
member who is unable to attend session
due to medical condition illness or
illness in the family to notify the
clerk and designate another member as
their proxy before close a business
before session
since we know that every vote matters
including votes on floor amendments and
procedural votes
that proxy would be empowered to cast a
vote on every Division and roll call
vote following the vote the clerk would
call on the member carrying the absent
member's proxy for them to publicly and
audibly cast their vote in front of the
entire chamber
no member attending session shall hold
more than one proxy for an absent member
and a physical Quorum must be present in
the house chamber for the proceedings to
remain valid
now those who oppose proxy voting May
cast out on the Integrity of this
process suggesting that members May
appoint a proxy and proceed to go on a
tropical vacation
in response I want to remind members
that they as well as members of the
public have the right to file an Ethics
complaint over such Behavior which would
be the appropriate place to refer such
an incident
those who oppose proxy voting may also
suggest that this proposal goes too far
by allowing members to vote on
procedural votes and floor amendments
in response I want to again remind the
body that in such a closely divided
chamber every vote counts including on
floor amendments and procedural votes
which may be unknown prior to session
day
given the full power and authority a
proxy has to represent the absent member
this does require a great deal of trust
and should that trust be broken an
x-complaint could be filed and or a new
proxy vote could be declared a new proxy
could be declared heading into the next
session
should there be a long-term illness or
medical condition that keeps a member
away from Representatives Hall long term
for those of us caring for children
parents
or other loved ones staying healthy and
keeping our loved ones healthy and safe
is very important work
as we begin our work together in this
new biennium there is the additional
consequence
should any of us get sick or our family
members get sick or absent from a close
vote at a house session
it's an added blow even though it
doesn't have to be that way
colleagues please join me in looking out
for one another's health and well-being
as we embark on this new session
together let's look out for our
constituents and ensure that every
Granite stator is fully represented
within the walls of this hallowed
chamber
even when one of us is unable to attend
in person due to medical condition
illness or illness in the family
having a contingency plan to see through
the commitments we've made to our
constituents and to each other as a
responsible approach to governance in
by voting to pass this floor amendment
to house rule 22 the New Hampshire house
will Empower itself
to follow this example of other
legislative Chambers across the country
and even the United States Congress
each utilizing proxy voting in their own
way to help fulfill their duties I
respectfully urge my colleagues to vote
Yes on this
floor Amendment thank you Mr Speaker
GI recognizes Representative Steven
Smith speak against the motion
thank you Mr Speaker
you know the the idea of one person one
vote that we hold sacred in this country
and it's enshrined in federal law
should we be any different I mean look
around at your colleagues which one of
them do you think should have twice the
voting power you do because this rule
doesn't require that you cast the votes
in the manner that the member intended
there's actually not even any recourse
in here if they don't other than that
the aggrieved party there can go
shopping for somebody else to cast their
votes with no hope or guarantee that
they will do the same thing functionally
this gives a member of the House two
votes
I should be able to just stop talking
there and sit down but I know better
today
there's no procedure here either so the
they notify the clerk that this person
is going to be my proxy let me tell you
about my morning
so I have a bad knee I gotta have it
replaced having that time or money to do
it yet that's a medical problem and this
morning I have branches in my remote
road that I have to get here I'm trying
to clear them I twist it up pretty bad
super intense pain can't take
painkillers because I got an almost two
hour drive it would have been very easy
for me to say you know what
my friend from Auburn he's just going to
cast votes for me from now on any time
there's bad weather because of the risk
of damaging my leg further
that's not what I signed up to do
I ran for office so that I could come
here and be the physical representation
of my district as the very least I owe
them and yeah it doesn't happen all the
time challenges happen
children get sick you hurt yourself you
get sick but you do the best you can
it's the very least that we owe them to
come here and not give our vote away to
someone else thank you Mr Speaker
and also be in order
[Music]
the question before us is the
roll call has been called for is that
sufficiently seconded it is sufficiently
seconded this will be a roll call vote
members will take your seats
[Music]
it's weird
members will be in your seats
this will be a roll call vote
chair recognizes
representative Wilhelm for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that other State's
legislative bodies and even the U.S
Congress have recently authorized proxy
voting as a way to protect the health
and safety of their members while
ensuring duly elected representatives
are provided the opportunity to vote
and if I know that On Any Given session
day there will be members of both
parties on both sides of the aisle who
may be home or hospitalized due to
medical condition illness or illness in
the family and others who will feel
significant pressure to show up in
Concord to cast a key vote despite
putting their own health and or the
health of their colleagues at risk and
Mr Speaker if I know that as the
minority leader of the sustained body
the caucus I lead statistically speaking
has less to gain by allowing for proxy
voting but that it's still worth doing
because it's the right thing to do and
would I now push the green button to
enfranchise every Granite stator with
full representation in this closely
divided chamber where every vote on
every bill will surely count this
session thank you Mr Speaker
I recognize the Representative Steven
Smith for parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that a
little less than two years ago when we
were trying to figure out how to meet
safely I proposed having people in
different rooms and have room captains
bring their votes chamber and if I
remember that that was that received
bipartisan condemnation as being akin to
proxy voting a precedent we should never
set here
if I know that no other state right now
is using proxy voting and that the
United States Congress is getting rid of
it
and finally Mr Speaker if those members
from the other party who told me I was
wrong
a little less than two years ago were
right then
and that they'll be right today when
they vote no would I press the red
button
the motion before us is the
representative wilhelm's amendment to
rule 22c
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
foreign
[Music]
represent Haskins could you just give me
a thumbs up or a thumbs down please
thank you
represent months just a thumbs up thank
you
well
representative king sorry we thought you
weren't going to be here today yes or no
thank you
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend the state of the vote
I also be an honor 171 voting yay on 204
voting a
the motion fails
representative evil moves to
the floor amendment to a house rule 31
chair recognizes represent available to
speak evil the speaker of floor
Amendment
speaker and happy New Year colleagues
long ago and far away before the
pandemic the vast majority of us had no
idea what Zoom was or Microsoft teams
many hadn't even attended a meeting
online
in March 2020 we sat here overnight
plowing through bills at what would be
the last house session in this chamber
for a really long time
it's been quite a journey and how things
have changed
at the speaker's discretion this
proposed amendment to house rule 31
would permit our house committees and
subcommittees to remit to meet remotely
or in hybrid in addition to meeting in
person as they do now
a quorum may be determined based on
Virtual attendance which was deemed
permissible by our state supreme court
this rule is required by Mason's rules
to permit us to go remote in our
committees you can ask the clerk
this simple Common Sense proposal
enables the speaker to take whatever
actions he feels appropriate with
respect to remote attendance for members
whether in an emergency or otherwise
as we learned two years ago one never
knows what the next day will bring this
body should be prepared to respond by
passing this rule change today why wait
it's a great rule to have in our rule
box
when the governor declared the state of
emergency for our state
speaker shirtleff and his team including
me had to act quickly to continue the
much needed legislative work we had to
do
long hours were spent with staff members
understanding various meeting programs
like learning what Zoom was developing
new protocols for the meeting setting up
member trainings learning how to mute
and unmute raise those darn little
yellow hands and get our videos on
providing for Testimony to be taken
getting the technology to live stream
our meetings and figuring out how to
Archive them
speaker Packard continued this work by
arranging for hybrid meetings with some
committee members in committee rooms and
others online
this was to keep us healthy but as we
have learned all this work had other
benefits for us as members and for the
public
today we have the technology for remote
participation the necessary media staff
and committee rooms wired for live
streaming we've successfully held
hundreds of remote and hybrid committee
meetings so now here we are in 2023 with
that experience and understanding we
should act accordingly
while not always ideal we learned that
providing the remote option for our
members makes our meetings more
inclusive it facilitates attendance for
those with health child care or family
challenges
having the remote option can help us
represent our constituents better
parents with sick children can still do
their jobs as legislators
substitute committee members are
terrific but they do not have the
knowledge base regular committee members
do
as we try to make the legislature more
inclusive particularly for those who are
younger have children or have to work it
behooves us to permit remote attendance
to be clear if this rule is adopted the
speaker need not re permit remote
testimony that is the speaker's decision
we now have the know-how and the support
system to permit remote participation
we should make our committee meetings
more open and facilitate remote
attendance we should pass this Common
Sense enabling amendment to house rule
31 permitting the speaker to act on
remote participation whether it be for
emergencies or day-to-day business
we do know how to do this and we should
press the green button to pass this
amendment
in the interest of time I'll take no
questions and Mr Speaker I request a
division vote thank you
I recognize that Representative Steven
Smith speak again the motion to speak
against the motion
well I have a little egg on my face
because I had the honor of working on
new legislative orientation and I just
got done telling them
that the very least that we can do for
the public and our constituents and one
of the most important things we do is to
come here and sit before them and hear
their problems
this could eliminate that
there is no worse look for the
legislatures yes this is very good for
legislators you don't have to come I
don't come here to do things that are
good for me I come here to do things
that are good for the public and
sometimes that's hard inconvenience
but I volunteered just like the rest of
you and I knew what I was signing up for
going in
during the pandemic I when we were
having virtual committee meetings I had
to introduce one of my bills I was here
working on other things anyway so I went
to the committee room
I was the only human being in the room
so like picture that there I am sitting
in a chair in the middle of the
committee room alone
and there are people on streams it was
like something out of a bad science
fiction movie
it gets worse then they start talking
about well where's representative Smith
he's supposed to be introducing his bill
I don't see him logged in and I'm
thinking really
like look at the darn camera I actually
had to start waving my arms
and then they noticed me and laughed
because they thought it was funny
what if there were members of the public
there to see that what if they were
watching to see that sort of circus
debacle it's embarrassing
we dress professionally when we come
here because we're showing the public
respect and committee hearings we sit
politely dressed well silently without
our Electronics open listening to the
public testify this is a duty that we
owe them
if you agree with me please vote against
this rule thank you Mr Speaker
well remember yield to a question
remember does not yield
is there a hole has requested a roll
call is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote members take your seats
thank you
the question before us is the four
amendment to rule 31.
this will be a roll call vote
the chair recognizes representative evil
for a parliamentary inquiry
if I know that passing this amendment
authorizes the speaker to permit remote
or hybrid attendance for house
committees and subcommittees as he sees
fit but does not require him to do so
if I know that allowing remote
attendance for members would enable
those with health child care or family
challenges to better fulfill their
responsibilities to their constituents
if I know we have the experience
knowledge and ability to operate house
committees remotely are in hybrid and we
know well how to do it
and if I know that we never know what
the next day will bring so we really
should be prepared would I now press the
green button to pass amend this
amendment to house rule 31.
Jay I recognize Representative Steven
Smith for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
in the absence of a state of emergency
if I know that this language violates
RSA 91a1 section 3B which only permits
virtual quorums in an emergency and Mr
Speaker if I know about this rule we
figured it out last time then what I've
pressed the red button to vote against
this unnecessary rule
the question before us is the floor
amendment to rule 31 this is a roll call
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
me
very important
Bailey
my clothes
fall members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend the state of the vote
180 voting a 195 voting a the amendment
fails
representative Sweeney is offering a
floor amendment to rules 46.
chair recognizes Representatives
well what reason does it member rise
to make a motion Mr Speaker
State your motion
Mr Speaker I would move to table this
rule Amendment
that is a proper motion so the motion
before us is the table and I would
request a division vote
the table before amendment to rule 46.
and a division has been requested
members take your seats
foreign
the question before us is the tabling
motion
to household 46
this is going to be a division vote the
chair recognizes representative Weber
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that the current
practice
when a committee has a divided vote
is to offer the ought to pass motion
first
and if I know that this rule is fair
because it is completely content neutral
and if I know that permitting the chair
or ranking the chair or the vice chair
of the committee to pick which motion
comes first
maybe quicker but it certainly negates
the work of the other 19 members of the
committee
and if I've heard here already that we
are here to do the people's work and not
to do it for our own convenience
would I now vote Yes on the tabling
motion to keep the process fair and with
a Level Playing Field thank you Mr
Speaker
I recognize the representative Sweeney
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that we
are here to do the people's work and not
for our own convenience and if I further
know that we should debate the house
rules by doing the people's work and
that this rule deserves to be debated
among this body and not simply put away
on the table would I now vote the red
button to not table this rule Amendment
thank you
the motion before us is the table the
floor amendment to house rule 646 this
is a division vote if you're in favor
you'll press a green button if you're
oppose you'll press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
have all members president had an
opportunity to vote
Gerald attended state of the vote
the house will be in order
the chair did vote
to make the tie thus the motion fails
the question before us it now is the
four amendment to house rule 66 to 46.
the chair recognizes Representatives
Sweeney
thank you Mr Speaker and I'm glad to be
debating this rule Amendment with all of
you today
uh it's a very simple rule amendment to
change the current practice of the house
my Amendment reads if a report comes to
the house without recommendation the
house shall first consider the motion of
the chair or vice chair if the chair is
absent of the committee makes on the
floor
we are really in unprecedented times
with the House of Representatives being
so close in number we recognize that
everybody in this room can recognize
that we are going to have a large number
of bills coming committee split 10 to
10. regardless of the content of the
bills regardless of what is going on who
is there on the day of committee these
votes are go and these motions that are
be made out of committee without
recommendation will be more frequent
this term than they ever have been
before
every time that we have to make a most
have a vote on emotion that is ought to
pass automatically out of the committee
that we might not have the votes for and
then we have to flip to take the time to
then make it to an itl is going to take
time out of our time here to do the
people's work
we got to remember the people that we
are fighting for when we're in this
house it's it's not all about the
procedures and the process and making
sure that we keep things the same way
and frankly we've seen a number of
offers of amendments today that would
change the way we we've done things I
didn't agree with them but this is a
modest change for the future of the
house so that we can navigate these next
two years fighting for the mother who
can't heat her house fighting for the
father struggling to pay grocery bills
we're going to fight for the people and
that's what this amendment does we're
going to empower the chairs or the vice
chairs of the Committees the people that
know what the legislation is going
through from their committees adhering
and and giving them the floor to make
the first motion on the bill it does not
mean necessarily that what the chair
makes a motion on is what's the house is
going to pass it just allows a little
bit more of a process to move forward
without an automatic ought to pass
motion on any bill that comes out of the
committee without recommendation and for
that I would implore you to vote yes
thank you
as a member yield to questions
remember does not yield
recognizes representative Weber's
thank you Mr Speaker
nothing
is going to keep the members of this
house
from passionately representing their
constituents nothing so no rule change
is going to change that
so that's the emotional bit right there
but we are in an unprecedented times
we are completely
we are we are virtually equally divided
and our committees are equally divided
and there was a great amount of
discussion and cooperation at the
beginning of the session
to achieve that end
but this rule completely turns that
bipartisan agreement on its head
because it gives all the power
to determine how a bill will proceed
not to the committee as a whole
but to one person on the committee
and the other 19 people's work
is therefore ignored
the point of having the ought to pass go
first is that it is completely content
neutral
and remember
some of the bills will come out ought to
pass some of them will come out you know
some some would prefer to have the main
expedient to legislate
but if we follow our traditions
we make sure that we are preserving the
honor of the work of every single member
of a committee and not giving one member
the say that each member's vote is
entitled to
so it may take us a little longer we
don't know
my suggestion has always been let's give
it a try for a couple of days
if it's too slow we can go on talking
about how to deal with this and if
there's a good bipartisan solution and I
think there is very good will on both
sides to keep talking about it
then we can always amend these votes by
a super majority these rules by a super
majority
so I would urge you to preserve the
Integrity of the committee process
let us not put our convenience over the
fairness that we have all pledged in
these unprecedented times and please
press the red button thank you
Xena Poole has requests that are all
call is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote
members take your seats
foreign
is the floor amendment to rule 46. chair
recognizes representative Sweeney for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that the chairs of our committees
are nonpartisan administrators of the
committee work and process in the New
Hampshire house also be in order
and if I further know we are only
empowering that committee process and
the chairs to speak with the caucuses of
both committee for what motion should
first be brought onto the floor through
this amendment in the timely fashion of
the house would I now press the green
button thank you
Jay I recognizer representative Weber
for parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that every single
one of the non-partisan administrators
of the Committees belong to one party
and I want to level the playing field
would I now push the red button to
defeat this motion thank you
the motion before us is the floor
amendment to rule 46. this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll
press a green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
foreign
remembers president had an opportunity
to vote
house will attended a state of the vote
184 voting a 191 voting a the motion
fails
Mr Speaker
for what reasons have memorized
the house will be in order
Mr Speaker having voted on the
prevailing side I would move
reconsideration and ask the members to
vote no on reconsideration
the motion the motion before us is a
reconsideration on the floor amendment
to
rule 46.
are you ready for the question
all those in favor of reconsideration
say aye
those opposed nay
is it
I'm in doubt
the house the house will have a division
vote
because I am in doubt
members that were here lonely
the motion before us is the
reconsideration motion
on the floor amendment to house rule 46.
motion voting stations are open
[Music]
presenter Perez
representative Perez
I need a guess or no thank you
representative Reed
is that gerhardt
well Memphis president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
the state of the vote
182 voting a 193 voting nay
reconsideration fails and that's why I
asked for it
representative Wilhelm proposes an
amendment how floor amendment to house
rule 64. the chair recognizes
representative muse from Portsmouth
the house will be in order the member
has a right to be heard
thank you Mr Speaker
the amendment before us today would
restore a house rule that until 2011 had
stood for 40 years
if we approve it carrying or possessing
deadly weapons in this chamber the
gallery and anti-rooms would once again
be prohibited
for the last few sessions changes in the
party controlling the majority have
controlled the fate of deadly weapons in
this chamber
under the current rule which this
amendment would change deadly weapons
can be brought into this chamber but
they must be concealed because
displaying them is prohibited
those who favor the current rule argue
that legislators and visitors deserve
the right to defend themselves
they claim that changing the rule to ban
guns from the chamber would make us soft
targets for terrorists and mass shooters
to that I would respectfully say welcome
to the club
this is a risk that school children in
New Hampshire and across the country
live with every day
not to mention people who walk into
grocery stores Hospital workers and
every person who Ventures outside their
home into a public place
with gun ownership now at a record high
and more firearms in circulation than
ever before it's become sadly apparent
that more guns in more places isn't part
of the solution
it's part of the problem
in this particular chamber the firing of
a weapon either intentionally in
self-defense or accidentally comes with
tremendous risks
take a look around this room and take a
look at your colleagues
look at a legislator who might be
sitting a few sections over from you and
draw a mental line between yourself and
that person
depending on where you sit and who
you're looking at that mental line you
just drew could intersect or come within
a few inches of a dozen or more of your
colleagues
now imagine that we're not talking about
a mental line
imagine that we're talking about a
bullet from a dropped firearm
inadvertently discharging something
that's already happened multiple times
or imagine that it's a bullet
intentionally discharged by a person uh
in a in a situation where uh adrenaline
is Flowing uh and where nobody really
quite understands what's going on in
response to a perceived threat
either way the risks are obvious in a
crowded chamber where legislators are
packed into seats like sardines and
where the gallery is quite often
frequented with children
in the years that deadly weapons have
been allowed in this chamber there have
been several incidents where Firearms
have been accidentally dropped
in a crowded room with cramped seating
that often forces many of us to Vault
over each other simply to do what I'm
doing now to speak at the well or just
to use the restroom the risk of
accidents and accidental discharges is
very real
but beyond concerns for Public Safety as
well as our own safety and our own
individual rights
this issue raises a key question
is this chamber an appropriate or a
necessary place for people to bring guns
or other weapons or should it be a place
reserved for Goodwill
healthy debates and our best ideas for
moving this state forward so all of our
constituents can lead Better Lives
we don't allow deadly weapons to be
carried into our courtrooms we don't
allow them to be carried into prisons
and whether openly displayed or
concealed we shouldn't allow them to be
carried into the people's house by
anyone other than Troopers and Security
Professionals trained to deal with these
situations
please vote Yes to support this
amendment
chair recognizes representative Roy
thank you Mr Speaker colleagues we were
just asked to do a lot of imagining
imagine this you live in a country where
you don't have to give a reason it's
your right the Constitution says it's
your right state law house rules do not
Trump the Constitution we've already
found that that last term when someone
tried to stop a member from carrying and
it went all the way to the Supreme Court
and that side argued that house rules
reign supreme the Supreme Court of the
state said no they do not the
Constitution Reigns Supreme so we don't
have to give a reason we don't have to
imagine it's our right to defend
ourselves and as I heard earlier no
house rule is going to stop the members
from defending themselves please vote
against this thank you
the house will be in order
representative who has requested a roll
call is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote members take your seats
foreign
thank you
the motion before us is the floor
amendment to rule 64. this is a roll
call vote
chair recognizes representative Wilhelm
for a parliamentary inquiry
speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that firearms and
representatives Hall did not used to be
a partisan issue and that for decades
there was bipartisan agreement that this
chamber was not an appropriate place for
deadly weapons
if I know that the State House
has well-trained armed security
personnel and state troopers who work
every day to protect us
and Mr Speaker if I know that accidents
do happen and that Firearms have been
mishandled on State House grounds on
multiple occasions in recent terms
than would I now vote to restore common
sense to our rules and press the green
button to adopt this amendment thank you
Mr Speaker
gee I recognize representative hoole for
a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr speaker thank you members
of the house if I know that when seconds
count right unfortunately law
enforcement are minutes away if I know
that this house has had a consistent
Problem free
version of this rule sorry not of this
role allowing Carrie in the house
for the last 15 or so years without a
problem
would I now oppose the adoption of this
amendment thank you
the motion before us is the four
Amendment
to house rule 64. it's a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if your opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
look that down
represent Murray representative mirin
thumb supper thumbs down
ball members president had an
opportunity to vote
household attend to the state of the
vote
177 voting a 197 voting a the motion
fails
representative Poole has a four
amendment to 50 rule 52.
I have no debate
I recognize representative Poole
members of the House
the consent calendar comes at the front
of the regular calendar every week
and having pulled a number of bills off
of consent in the eight years I was here
I can testify to the fact that I
probably pulled more than most
and there's lots of reasons to pull a
bill
but out of all the bills I pulled off
consent I was successful in flipping it
once
House Bill 668 in 2016 it was a 19-0
vote out of committee after about a
month we got the bill flipped from an
itl to an auto pass
the success rate on Flipping bills on
the floor is very very low when it's
pulled off of consent
the reason I introduce this amendment is
if there's any desire to actually have a
discussion finding 10 other people to
agree with you is not a difficult task
if you want to voice your opposition to
the clerk on a bill you can submit a
little slip of paper saying I didn't
like house bill whatever and it can be
noted in the permanent Journal
six minutes in this chamber equates to
one man week worth of time we should be
very careful about how we use the house
time
I don't want to see someone take and
pull a bunch of bills off consent and
force everyone to sit in their seats
for several hours just to delay the
proceedings I would ask for your support
on this thank you
Geo recognize representative verville
thank you Mr speaker thank you
colleagues
um starting my fourth term in the New
Hampshire House of Representatives and
I'm I'm honored to be here as you all
are we are often cautioned against
looking for solutions to problems that
don't exist so do bills get pulled off
of consent yes they do
sorry to hear about the representatives
you know inability to get those
committee recommendations flipped when
he pulled them off consent but in three
terms three full terms I've never seen
abuse of pulling bills off of consent I
pulled one off last session I I knew
that bill was going nowhere but I owed
it to my constituents to fight the good
fight and those those debates are
usually very limited in in time and so
there's only one story I've ever heard
of of a representative from from
Manchester who may or may not have
pulled every bill off consent and then
promptly went home
but that's kind of elegant too right I
mean that's you got to tip your hat to
that this is this is a solution chasing
a problem that doesn't exist and for
that reason I would encourage you to
vote uh against this rule Amendment
thank you Mr Speaker
motion before us is the floor amendment
to house rule 52. are you ready for the
question
division has been requested
representative Dan McGuire requests a
division members will take your seats
this will be a division vote
clear
the motion before us is the floor
amendment to roll 52 a house will be in
order
this will be a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
representative spear
representative Newell
representative Leafly
if one remembers president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend a state of the vote
206 voting yay 167 voting a the
amendment is adopted
years
representative Dotsy has a floor
amendment to rule 58. chair recognizes
representative dutzy
Mr Speaker and colleagues my floor
amendment is very simple and only
changes one word
can you hear oh you can't hear me okay
how's that
okay okay
oh
okay Mr Speaker and colleague
my floor amendment is very simple and
only changes one word
under order of business I am requesting
that rule 58 subparagraph a number one
be changed from prayer to invocation
it would then read invocation by the
chaplain or a substitute designated by
the speaker
Webster's New World college dictionary
the fourth edition
defines invocation as quote the act of
calling on God capital g a god small g a
saint the muses for a blessing whereas a
prayer is defined as quote the act or
practice of praying to God capital G
as the word prayer speaks more to
religion invocation has a broader
meaning which can be spiritual in nature
but not necessarily religious an
invocation can be a prayer but it does
not need to be a prayer
although many in this chamber seek
guidance from a higher being others seek
guidance and centering from more Earthly
imagery the Majesty of walking through a
forest for example or Pursuits such as
the camaraderie of working on a shared
task
the word invocation allows for the
inclusion of these and similar images in
the opening of our sessions and I ask
for your consideration in making this
change
thank you
motion the motion before us is the floor
Amendment
to house rule 58.
are you ready for the question
representative verbill requests a roll
call us that's efficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded members will
take your seats
a motion before us is the
floor amendment to house rule 58. chair
this is a roll call vote chair
recognizer represent Simpson for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr
if I know that the term invocation is
frequently used to describe the
religious or spiritual act at the
beginning of an event or a ceremony
and if I know that the term invocation
takes into account the multiplicity of
religious and spiritual practices of
house members of visitors and of granite
Staters
and finally if I know that using the
term invocation doesn't inhibit the work
of the chaplain
would I now press the green button to
make this small but meaningful change to
the rules thank you chair recognize
representative for a parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if if I
know we've heard a lot of reasons why we
should honor tradition and not be making
changes for the sake of making changes
uh Mr Speaker if I also know that it is
actually not unheard of to have
invocations and not technically prayers
given at the opening of
foreign
if I know oh hey if I know Mr Speaker
that invocations have been given and not
technically prayers at the beginning of
session and that there is of course no
no ban on giving an invocation over
giving a prayer uh then Mr Speaker would
I now not pre would I now press the red
button so that we do not change this one
word in this one rule and we stick with
our Traditions thank you Mr Speaker
the motion before us is the floor
amendment to rule 58. this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if we oppose you
or press the red button voting stations
are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
so well members president an opportunity
to vote
also attend the state of the vote
183 voting yay 190 voting a the motion
fails
representative Prout moves floor
amendment to rule 58.
but
wait a minute representative
chair recognizes representative Prout
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker
it was about speeches under unanimous
consent to the house usually at the end
of our day after the third reading
motion
these speeches aren't on the topic of
the business aren't on a topic of
business before the house they're about
anything else a member would like to
publicly mention
Memorial remarks remarks about an
important event in history
or even one member has used the time to
wish his wife a happy anniversary as he
was stuck in session on that special day
the current process is that if unanimous
consent is withdrawn it triggers a vote
on if the member should be allowed to
continue with the consent of the house
this currently requires a simple
majority of those present
this rule change would require a sixty
percent majority of those present for
the member to continue speaking
we have had several instances of issues
with this in the past where it came down
to a party line vote
I don't think this serve serves anyone
well nor the house as an institution to
have a party line votes on this topic
with our razor thin division between the
parties this term every vote under the
existing rule will be a toss-up
especially at the end of the day
this is an area where I think it makes
sense to require a super majority and
that off-topic speeches like this should
only be made with bipartisan agreement
of the members and this rule would
Implement that by setting the bar at
three-fifths
I ask you to vote Yes to pass this rule
change thank you Mr Speaker
the motion before us is the
floor amendment to house rule 58.
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted
Zen of Weber
has a four amendment to house rule 58
chair recognizes representative Weber
I agree entirely with the previous
speaker and what we just passed is one
half of the amendment that I suggested
after discussion with colleagues on both
sides of the aisle
one of the things that has happened once
once an objection to consent has
happened
according to Mason's rules it may not be
removed renewed so you get to object
once
and that's it
at least once in this chamber that has
been used by somebody who before a
member even began to speak
got up and said
I have jacked
and we all sat here and wondered why
they were objecting
well we all voted to let the members
speak
and then the members strayed into some
more politically
charged Waters
and somebody stood up and said I object
and the clerk said
he can't renew the objection because
Masons doesn't allow it and it's not in
our house rules
so the what the second part of my
Amendment does is it allows the
objection to be renewed once we don't
want to do this forever nobody wants to
be here all night
but the objection can be renewed once if
somebody Strays into murky Waters so I
urge the adoption of this amendment
which incorporates the earlier Amendment
thank you
the motion before us is the division
floor Amendment
to house rule 58 a division has been
requested members will take their seats
foreign
amendment to rule house rule 58.
this is a division vote chair recognizes
representative Weber for a parliamentary
inquiry
Mr Speaker if we've already done good
work but if there's a little more work
to be done and I want to be able to
renew an objection one time
to keep us on track
would I then press the green button
thank you
chair I recognize representative proud
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know there have been discussions about
this second part that the previous
representative mentioned and that we
have not yet come to a full agreement on
how it should be handled and if I also
know that the amendment before us does
not mesh well with the previous
amendment that we passed and the
language and the rules will then get
very convoluted as to what parts should
control if we were to pass both would I
now press the red button
and not pass this amendment
the motion before us is the
amendment to house rule 58. this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you approach
you'll press the red button reporting
stations are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
the whole
you can't push it down
representative
wall members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend the state of the vote
200 voting a 193 voting nay the motion
passes
Jay recognizes a clerk for a motion Mr
Speaker representative Ladd moves that
the house vacate the reference of House
Bill 207 relative to school district
unanticipated funds to the committee on
education
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it
and to all seven is referred to
committee on finance for what reason is
the member rise to make a motion Mr
Speaker stage of motion yeah I'd like to
move that the debate on the previous
rule change that we just passed by a
vote of 200 to 173 be placed into the
permanent journal to make it clear that
the renewal of an objection is is once
and and only once and that it can't be
recurring
the motion is to print the remarks
without objection
representative Reed has a floor
amendment to house rule 100.
chair recognizes representative Reed
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker the rules change before us
here would simply say that if a chair
and committee institutes a time limit
that that time limit be applied equally
I think this is something we all
understand to be basic fairness and
indeed most good chairs already
observe that practice there are
certainly some conditions in which a
chair might have to change time limit or
Institute a time limit for example
if a hearing is going long in a time
limit was not instituted but then has to
be instituted or if for example there's
an expert that's relaying information
that only that expert is privy to that
is why in this rule change
the statement is included if this
process cannot be followed the chairman
must submit a statement explaining why
this could not be done for the committee
file so it's not onerous if there are
legitimate reasons that the chair cannot
follow this all they have to do is
submit the statement for the clerk and
for the committee file
but this would help discover encourage
something that has happened in the past
which is the abuse of this
predominant precedent
and Mr Speaker I request a division
remember yielded questions
yes Mr Speaker member yields
representative American choir thank you
Mr speaker thank you for taking my
question I'm just trying to get this
straight so if there's a time limit set
for the amount of speakers because
there's too many looks like there's
going to be a lot of speakers then the
chair would not have the discretion to
say I'll give an example from my
committee the Science and Tech that the
commissioner of the Department of energy
is speaking and he gets to have more
time than a private individual from
Massachusetts who just happens to drive
up and want to talk on a subject that
that wouldn't be allowed that is
incorrect as I just explained as I just
explained the purpose of this rule is to
prevent the abuse of what has been
practiced in the past to prevent
basically paltry political game playing
with time limits and that is why if a
chair does choose to change time limit
halfway through or allow a particular
expert all they have to do is submit a
note into the committee file say saying
why that they could not or chose not to
do that
there's the member yield or further
question
oh yes I do so it seems to me as if it
doesn't really accomplish anything
because if the if the Chairman's doing
this if the chairman is doing this
because
this is a question representative he
could just justify that by writing down
whatever he wanted the point is to
discourage what I would just simply
bluntly call cheating and so if you have
to come up with an actual reason that
you cannot allow equal time to everybody
but your actual reason was paltry
politics then you'd have to come up with
something creative if you know that you
have to disclose that in advance then
maybe you don't do that
I request a division
does remember yield a further question
last one
thank you representative
occasionally we've all seen a committee
uh someone comes in to testify and they
get very emotional they break down into
tears
I've seen it I'm sure you've seen it and
when that occurs I would like to think
that the chair would have the discretion
to give that individual some extra time
without being constrained by this type
of limitation could you could you
respond to that please absolutely once
again that would be a simple note by the
chair placed into the committee file the
person providing testimony was
experiencing emotional distress and had
to be given extra time to compose
themselves
do you recognize the representative hunt
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker as a past chairman for many
years there have been situations where
you kind of recalibrate what's going on
in the committee
I myself personally would always make
any changes in discussing it with the
minority or the opposite party and I
don't think that the idea of putting
this in rules is really going to make
people do things better or do something
more on us or do something right writing
a note is seems a little extraneous to
be sticking in a file and let alone
would it would people second guess what
the chairman was doing
the end of the day we got our YouTube
everybody can see what happened in the
committee and then everyone can be the
judge of what the chair did
motion before us is the floor amendment
to house rule 100.
are you ready for the question
a division has been requested members
will take their seats
success
the motion before us is the floor
amendment to house rule 100. this is a
division vote
if you're in if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
to press the red button voting stations
are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
thank you
all members president an opportunity to
vote
also attend the state of the vote
114 voting a 256 voting a
motion fails
Cassandra Reed offers a floor amendment
to house rule 106. care recognizes
representative Reed
how's the house will be in order
remember he has a right to be heard
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
um house rule 106 simply codifies what
is already supposed to be our practice
which is to say a member any member can
participate in a hearing from either one
side or the other of the table either
they testify or they question they do
not do both and that that rule will
apply equally to everybody it is
predominantly the practice but has not
always been equally applied and I think
that the people of this state deserve to
have uniformity in how their bills are
treated here regardless of the committee
chair that happens to be sitting on that
committee that day so it's fairly simple
and that's about it
the motion before us is the floor
Amendment to house rule 106.
are you ready for the question
a division has been requested members
will take their seats
problems
the motion before us is the floor
amendment to house rule 106. this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're a
Polish you'll press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
foreign
[Music]
represent Jeffrey Smith
wall members president had an
opportunity to vote I also attend the
state of the vote
200 voting yay 169 voting a the motion
passes
chair recognizes the member from Auburn
representative Osborne for a motion to
adjourn from the early session
they get resolved that the house now
adjourned from the early session that
the business of the late session be in
order at the present time and when the
house adjourns today it be to meet on
Thursday January 5th 2023.
ask the members to stay in your seats
until we're done we're almost there
are you ready for the question all those
in favor to say aye
there's opposed nay the eyes have it and
emotion is adopted
the house will attend to announcements
the chair recognizes representative
Carol McGuire for a announcement
the house will be in order
we're almost done
thank you Mr Speaker members of Edna
were having orientation on Monday and if
you want a copy of the performance audit
that we will be discussing it is
available in room 306.
Gia recognizes a clerk for an
announcement thank you Mr Speaker I have
a few announcements to share one uh from
organization day to today you may have
noticed if you've been in the back that
the mailboxes have been fixed so please
note that they may not be in the same
place that they were on organization day
as you know the Department of Motor
Vehicles is here for license plates and
legislative IDs across the street in the
Legislative Office Building in room 103
in room 104 for freshman members there
are your key cards to be able to enter
the building also your security lapel
pins so you can swing by and get those
there they will be here tomorrow as well
if you are not going to be here tomorrow
beginning at one o'clock today there
will be an anti-harassment excuse me not
one o'clock 30 minutes after we break
I'm looking for the chief of staff 30
minutes after we break today there will
be an anti-harassment termination
training Happening Here in reps Hall it
will be put on by the Attorney General's
office and all members are encouraged to
attend this week begins the opt-in
process for the mailing of house
calendars if you have not opted in to
receive your calendar VIA mail please
come down after session and we will take
your name and and we will add you to the
mailing list and I want to just take a
moment to address the USPS issue we are
aware that there is a USPS issue I have
sent calendars that have come back to me
two weeks later that were addressed
properly we I have been in touch with
the federal Congressional Delegation
about this issue we are working on it we
hope to resolve it but please be mindful
that we we are sending them out on time
and I apologize that they are not
getting to you on time please be please
remember that they are published online
on the afternoon of Thursday and uh they
if you need to print them out or we do
have copies here so if you want to opt
out of mailing that's fine we will have
copies here uh another announcement
sorry Financial disclosures only 153 of
you have completed thus far you are
required by Statute RSA 14 that you must
file your financial statement once per
biennium you can do this through the
portal online if you are having issues
with that you can see Rich Lambert down
in the office of legislative Services
lastly representative Fitzpatrick you
left your name tag over in the lob I
have that upstairs for you
I just quickly like to thank all those
who attended the
training uh two weeks ago on civility
I missed some of it but I saw some of it
I think it's something that everybody
can take notice of and and try and apply
over the next two years
representative Horrigan requests
unanimous consent
thank you thank you very much Mr Speaker
and also a congratulations on your
re-election which we did in one ballot
um
so even if nothing had happened at the
capitol or anywhere else that day
Wednesday January 6 2021 would have been
an unforgettable day for me and everyone
else who was serving in the house last
session that was the day we held our
convening day session when we just
completed successfully no at unhs Aid
lot and it was especially memorable for
me because it happened in my own
neighborhood just a few blocks from my
house well the members has been for a
minute
yeah we're almost almost completely done
we still need a quorum for the final
motion so please everybody just stay put
for a few more minutes thank you
remember may continue it's um my remarks
are pretty short anyway the parking lot
session was a it was a wacky idea but we
we pulled it off we completed our work
successfully and peacefully
things were less peaceful at the Capitol
although the Congress
eventually finish this work in the wee
hours of Thursday January 7th um no
thanks to now former president Trump on
January 6th I still
[Music]
um
the met the member shouldn't be
referring
to any former president in any
disrespect
okay
let's um
okay anyway that day I was using an old
phone with weak battery and
um what's weaker than my current phone
also there's no Wi-Fi in a lot so I was
unable to see the video from Washington
DC's but I could see the headlines and
of course I was busy with I work in the
parking lot so I didn't grasp a full
magnitude what happened until I got
panicky phone calls from family members
now it's a blessing not seeing that
video in real time it spared me
personally some of the shock and I'm
horrified and still horrified and I
don't think it matters whoever will
suspend fall for it it was horrifying
the member will suspend all right thank
you
representative Summers has withdrawn his
consent
with the first test case of the new
procedure thank you
okay
I guess
I guess like any other the member will
suspend we have to vote
members need to take your seats this is
going to be a
division vote
we need the count
I have to agree
foreign
tonight
members will be in their seats
this will be a division vote
and it takes 60 percent for the
Three-Fifths for the members to continue
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button boarding stations
are open for 30 seconds
all members president had an opportunity
to vote
also attend a state of the vote
seven also be an order 77 voting a 272
voting a the member may not continue
for what reasons does a member rise
thank you Mr Speaker
forgive me I don't
[Music]
parliamentary
I'm curious to know what is the specific
rule and in which of our
documents are we not allowed to say
something that would be considered
disparaging of a U.S a former U.S
president
I'm just
disparaging remarks are
are about anybody and ever allowed in
this chamber that that goes for that's
that's been a pretty much a standing
tradition for a long time
I don't think I actually meant
disparaging as much as criticism of a
former uh constructive criticism of a
former U.S president well that that's
that's disparaging remarks okay just
clarifying they I would like to know
what the um specific rule it or part of
our documents that we follow that says
that just so we can fully understand
genuinely just curious nothing nefarious
in asking this
will will it will address that in in our
next notice
representative ours
yes what for remember the reason is a
member rise
practice and precedent of this house
for long since before I was here that we
do not disparage other people nor do we
impart motive to other people because
that's simply not helpful in our debates
you are right representative thank you
thank you Mr Speaker
I'll also be in order
representative Osborne moves
at the house stand in recess for the
purpose of introduction of bills vacate
motions and receiving messages are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
also closed nay you guys have it and the
motion is adopted
a the the house that house is in recess
to the call of the chair
oh I I wait a minute wait I'm sorry
until 11 15.
tomorrow where the governor will be
sworn in